absolutely a dog you saved the best for
uh last what an incredible game and
display of an attacking chess tell us
about this opening preparation oh well
uh we actually play and analyze this a
lot at my University just okay
so I thought I'd give it a try it seems
to pose a lot of problems for blacks
absolutely just to interrupt you for a
second I think these two players are
about to shake hands we see Shabbat
right now looking at the score sheets
probably checking whether it's a
three-time repetition
I have a feeling this one or
if by the way it finishes in a draw we
have a champion yes we do we have a new
senior Champion uh I I I think we was
about to shake hands I think we should
stay with this moment right here for a
second
and the the the claim was wrong
and somebody's getting a minute it was
inaccurate because the queen on E5 was
three times but in fact once the bishop
was on C1 instead of G5 oh my goodness
okay come on well thank you for that
your accuracy and attention the detail
is noted let's stay with this by the
Arbiters as well I think we're gonna see
two more moves in another claim and this
time it is going to be accurate actually
Queen F6 maybe
and that's it that gives us the champion
uh say our new 2023 Champion wow
congratulations Grandmaster Malik said
kachin the new 2023 U.S Senior Champion
winning twenty thousand dollars
it's not a bad payday
very nice
and very very well deserved yes yes yes
he got lucky with his game with Igor
novikov sometimes you but look at all
the other games that he won and he won
beautifully so our congratulations and
that's to you congratulations Doug
I mean tell us once again this is
Collegiate prep yes I keep telling them
collegial chess is very serious and they
don't believe me this is Collegiate
level prep nice and tell us a bit about
this what if he takes this point uh then
F5 is usually best F5 and now uh what's
the best move does he have to just like
drop back uh he could play Bishop D7 or
Bishop C4 Bishop C4 then rookette4
and then like B5 Rook takes C4 okay some
crazy stuff yeah my goodness
okay you take Queen D5 and then the game
continues but and at Bishop D7 then
there's F6
or queen maybe Queen H5 it you can
either play F6 immediately or queen H5
and then F6 we were look looking at this
and there was this position and then
it's completely Rook up four and whites
it's equal it's more or less Dynamic
quality yeah right there yeah it's a
sharp position good luck finding all the
moves up until this point that's right
no uh my opponent was I I was amazed at
how well and how quickly he navigated
through all of this exactly because it's
not easy right I think is the best move
at least by now he's a great player and
he showed it early on unfortunately he
had problem a problem at the end he did
but I mean you were still keeping the
pressure going these two points are
always going to be extremely dangerous
no matter what happened and this was the
moment
I think Queen to E4 was perhaps the best
move but even that is very common it
remains very complicated yeah Queen C5
E7
Bishop to C6 and now you're already
starting to take over Rook to d8 and
Rook to B7 you know
Rook takes Queen E4 no I should just
play King AJ king h8 or King G8 yeah
either one what was your plan uh after
this move came to GA well I I can't play
King F1 because Bishop B5 check run uh
so that's a problem that's checking yeah
right
uh so I thought I'd probably have to
take the rook
and yeah you should be able to hold this
and then we play this position basically
yeah he's not getting checkmated no he
did miss this EA yeah and this is uh
game over well Doug I mean you started
off slowly but finally you're coming
back in the tournament you start a
tournament it feels like you want to
start a tournament Anew yeah
still one round to go who are you
playing tomorrow uh Patrick
still one big game to go guys any
questions congratulations Doug very very
nice back-to-back wins and good luck for
today tomorrow's game yeah
congratulations I have one question are
you a big fan of gambits because some
place really like it I used to play it
kind of when I was younger but then you
reach some strong level in chess and you
stop playing gambits but I still see you
really enjoying these crazy sacrifices
do you still play gambits a lot uh yes I
I enjoy some gambits and I also like to
play against Gambit sometimes
it's all about that Collegiate press
guys
go back to school yeah sir I'll give you
scholarship come back to school
congratulations Doug uh by the way we
also have a result Ru yang